فنان [موسيقى] أجنبي
من إثيوبيا
عندما كان عمري 12 عامًا ، تم تشخيص إصابتي
بالتهاب الفقار الملائكي وهو مرض
نادر يصيب العظام
عندما كان عمري 17 عامًا ونصف ، أصبت بالشلل التام ،
ثم أوقفت كل اللوحات التي
أتعلمها وكل شيء  أتخلى عن
صديقي في العمل في الجري
والقيام بأشياء جيدة ، لكنني لست
في ذلك الوقت ، لذلك شعرت بالسوء
حيال
نفسي وبعد تسع سنوات من العيش بهذه الطريقة
بدأت أدرك أنه يجب أن
أفعل شيئًا يجب أن أبدأ بالرسم  مرة أخرى
بسبب مرضي الذي أعاني منه ،
لا يمكنني الرسم تمامًا مثلما يمكن للفنانين الآخرين
القيام بذلك ، فقد توصلت إلى هذه الفكرة
وأستلقي رأسًا على عقب على الأرض
وأضع القماش على الأرض
وأقوم بفناني
الآن أفعل ذلك فقط  مثلما اعتدت أن أفعل ذلك
عندما أقف وأرسم
في البداية ، كان الأمر صعبًا بالنسبة لي
لأن الطريقة التي أفعلها هي
أنها سببت لي القليل من الصداع وأيضًا الكثير
من المشاكل في ذلك الوقت ولكن مع مرور الوقت
قمت بتغيير  الكثير أبدأ في إدارة توقيت بلدي
من 30 دقيقة إلى ساعة واحدة وساعتين
وثلاث ساعات الآن يمكنني الرسم لمدة 10 ساعات
باستمرار
لدي الكثير من الفرق التي أرسمها
في الماضي ولكن أحد الفرق التي
أحضرتها إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة هو التسامح في
تقاليدنا في إثيوبيا عندما  نطلب
المغفرة نحمل حجرًا في
نباحنا لأن التسامح
له معنى
احترام شخص ما في العيش
معًا
[موسيقى]
منذ أن جئت إلى دبي بدأت في
القراءة عن قادة UA هنا هو
تاريخ الإمارات العربية المتحدة وهذا يجعلني مصدر
إلهام وهو  يجعلني أتساءل كيف
حدث هذا بسبب قائد
موقع UA Sheikh
[الموسيقى]
الذي فعلته عندما تواجه مشكلة
عندما تدخل في إشارات ، حاول تغيير
الطريقة التي تعيش بها تمامًا
عندما أدخل  في هذه الحالة أغير الطريقة
التي أرسم بها
أجنبيًا